kentucky
has now essentially banned abortion in
the state
this is almost certainly a violation of
roe v wade but the supreme court is
going to rule in what is at this point
only weeks
whether roe v wade is essentially gone
and that's the really scary part of this
vox reporting it is now practically
impossible to get an abortion in
kentucky a new law is forcing the
state's last remaining abortion
providers to shut down
vox reporting kentucky ended virtually
all in-state abortions wednesday
enacting a sweeping law that bans
abortions after 15 weeks of pregnancy
restricts minors access to the procedure
and cracks down on medication abortions
it's now the state with the harshest
abortion restrictions in the united
states the new law goes into effect
immediately it will force the state's
two remaining abortion clinics in
louisville to close due to onerous new
requirements on doctors forcing
kentuckians to look elsewhere for
abortion care so
uh again this almost certainly violates
roe v wade roe v wade says
that
the constitution
protects women's liberty to choose to
have an abortion
without excessive government restriction
now excessive government restriction
is the source of much controversy and
opens itself up to significant
interpretation so
excessive restriction allows some
restriction but not too much
and under roe v wade
closing putting such onerous
requirements on abortion providers such
that they all close
would without a doubt in any sensible
interpretation of roe v wade be
considered to be uh unconstitutional
that that's onerous if the if the
requirements are so strict that every
provider in the state closes and people
seeking an abortion have to go to a
different state
that would violate roe v wade
by any sensible interpretation
but
this will be appealed of course
but in so in that process during that
process the supreme court might decide
in june
we are going to effectively overturn roe
v wade by allowing extremely harsh state
laws to stand
roe v wade could be gone in a few weeks
and as is often the case
in red states that are trying to ban
abortion
many of those states are an economic and
educational and health care disaster
i've said this so many times before the
states that are obsessed with these
cultural issues
are disastrous states by almost every
metric if you look at kentucky for
example kentucky is 43rd out of 50 in
terms of healthcare
kentucky is 40th out of 50 in terms of
its economy
kentucky is 48th out of 50 in fiscal
stability
44th in education and 47th in terms of
poverty rate
and yet their focus is let's try to ban
abortion
we've talked before
at minimum at minimum if you want to ban
abortion
you should include all sorts of support
for the expectant mothers and parents
because all of these additional children
being born
that folks
in theory wanted to uh uh
not have born so you're going to give
them financial support right well no no
no that's not right either and this all
ties back i haven't used the i used to
talk about this a lot i haven't for some
period of time this is what's called
strict father morality you know the
strict dad who says well
it's the principle it's the principle
they want to control women's bodies they
have a religious view on uh you know
sexual intercourse is supposed to be
strictly for procreation
and they're against comprehensive sex
education and often they're against
contraception so so that doesn't all
wait but you you don't want
abortion
but you also don't want to do the things
to prevent unintended pregnancy what do
you want and they say well we want
procreative sex in the context of
marriage and anything outside of that
means one needs to suffer the
consequences that's the right morality
if you get pregnant you've got to have
the kid and you've got to deal with
paying for all of the expenses of the
kid as well wait but so
that doesn't make sense because we know
that one of the best ways to prevent
unwanted pregnancy
is
total and complete access to
contraception
comprehensive sex education that's how
you prevent unwanted pregnancy excellent
study out of st louis looked at this oh
no but that wouldn't be the right
morality because that would open the
door
to people just having sex and that no no
no that doesn't go with our morality
it's uh completely backwards
it is antiquated thinking it is
non-science thinking but horrifyingly
and particularly if the supreme court
decision at the end of june effectively
reverses roe v wade
this is going to be the law of the land
in many many red states now as i've said
before
what should the people in these states
do
because on the one hand
one approach would be well we need
progressives and center-left democrats
and whatever to move to these states
to change the laws by becoming involved
in local government yeah but that's a
big uphill battle it's almost easier to
say to the folks who are rational and
clear thinking
leave those states and go to a blue
state
but the problem is a lot of people can't
afford to do that so it really is a
disastrous situation i don't know
what the abortion landscape is going to
look like say 12 months from now a big
piece of that is because we don't know
what the supreme court will decide in a
few weeks and another part of that is we
don't know to what degree
red states will continue pushing these
types of laws every indication is that
red states are determined to push this
stuff another reason yet as if we needed
more reasons yet another reason
why the upcoming midterm elections are
so consequential and by that i mean it's
not just about who we elected the u.s
senate and the u.s house of
representatives but there are tons of
local elections as well that are going
to set the tone governor's races state
senates state houses of representatives
we will talk about it more we'll talk
about what's at stake but it is a very
very big deal we'll have more on this
on our instagram you can find the david
pakman show on instagram
by searching david pakman show on
instagram